unweit der Kathedrale Sacre Coeur doch
fern von Touristen liegt das
einwandererviertel gut doch ein Viertel
Reich ein Geschichten aber auch eines
der ärmsten von Paris
hier lebt Lina mit ihrer Familie
aufgewachsen ich kenne alle hier
das ist mein das ist unser
und mittendrin der squarium ihr
Bolzplatz
in meiner Klasse sagen die Jungs wir
sind besser als du du bist doch bloß ein
Mädchen
in einer Gesellschaft in der
traditionelle Rollen immer noch gelebt
werden kämpfen sich die Mädchen durch
Rückschläge gibt es immer wieder zuletzt
durch die Unruhen in vielen Städten
Frankreich
in solchen Momenten profitieren wir von
unserer täglichen Arbeit im Verein
in kleinen Schritten beharrlich zum Ziel
Lina und die andere Mädchen sind früh
aufgestanden obwohl Wochenende ist
auf einem Bolzplatz in gutdorf im
Pariser Norden treffen sie sich zum
Training anders als ihre Brüder sind sie
nicht mit Fußball aufgewachsen lina ist
neu im Verein und manchmal noch etwas
unsicher
t
doch nach und nach wächst das
Selbstvertrauen in der Gruppe
so können wir im Viertel zeigen dass es
auch Mädchen gibt die Fußballspielen
nicht nur Jungs die meiste Zeit besetzen
die Jungs den Platz und wir Mädchen
trauen uns nicht dorthin zu gehen
Jungs müssen draußen bleiben heißt es
seitdem einmal die Woche auf dem
squarium die kicken derweil auf dem
Rasen nebenan das Fußballfeld ist für
die Mädchen reserviert die sich hier im
Quartier mehr und mehr Respekt
verschaffen
schneller erste Station 2 Station
Adam kommt aus Marokko und studiert seit
zwei Jahren in Paris er motiviert die
Mädchen und hat es geschafft auch deren
Eltern zu überzeugen
gerade ein Problem füttern wie diesem
hier ist es nicht immer leicht die
Mädchen zu erreichen
früher hatte ich kein großes
Selbstbewusstsein war er für mich
aber seitdem ich im Verein bin rede ich
mehr mit anderen
Barbara ich habe neue Freundinnen
gefunden außerhalb der Schule
jetzt ist das Meer im Verein
der Altersunterschied ist groß und doch
sind sie einige Gemeinschaft einige von
ihnen leben erst seit kurzem in der
Stadt die meisten sind in Frankreich
geboren eine migrationsvergangenheit
haben fast alle und die Erfahrung sich
als Fußballspiel in der Mädchen
durchsetzen zu müssen
besser als du du bist doch bloß ein
Mädchen selbst wenn ich ein Tor schieße
sagen sie das zählt nicht weil es ihnen
peinlich ist dass ich getroffen habe und
ich sage schaut her wir sind nicht
anders als ihr
auch deshalb will Linda möglichst viele
Mädchen für den Fußball gewinnen
ein paar Freundinnen haben gesagt komm
nach gut doch und ich habe meinen Vater
gefragt und er sagte okay ich bin ihm
dafür sehr dankbar
fußball ist nur ein Bereich des Vereins
der schlicht und ergreifend die Kinder
von gut doch heißt also wie das Viertel
Frankreich verfolgt schon lange eine
Sportförderung die eng mit sozialer und
integrative Arbeit verbunden ist oft
verbringen die Mädchen den ganzen Tag
zusammen nasser einer der vereinsleiter
denkt sich jedes mal was Neues aus
und was gibt es heute
und wer weiß wie das geht
[Musik]
Dunja versucht es zumindest und alle
helfen mit dankbar mit den Freundinnen
zusammen zu sein und eine Beschäftigung
am Wochenende zu haben
[Musik]
wir sind eine Ergänzung zu den Familien
eine Ergänzung der Schule aber wir
wollen wieder das eine noch das andere
ersetzen wir sind nicht besser als das
eine oder andere und das sagen wir immer
ganz offen und glauben auch daran für
uns ist das Wichtigste dass das Kind
ausgeglichen ist
die Kinder wissen dass sie hier immer
ein offenes Ohr haben für ihre Sorgen
und Abwechslung heute spielen sie Stadt
Land Fluss in einer etwas anderen
Variante
Marokko das Land ihrer Sommerferien die
bald beginnen und das Land ihrer Mutter
Radja
die erzählt dass Lina und ihr kleiner
Bruder bis vor kurzem eher
ängstliche Kinder waren sich wenig
zugetraut haben bis sie den Verein
entdeckt haben und zunächst bosian der
kleine Bruder den ersten Schritt auf den
Fußballplatz gewagt hat
an dem Tag als sie ihren Bruder spielen
sah und dann zu mir kam um zu sagen ich
will auch mitmachen da war ich froh dass
sie sich ein Hobby gesucht hat außerhalb
der Schule
seitdem haben sie sich total verändert
sie sind viel selbstständiger und nicht
mehr so schüchtern
[Musik]
ist voll berufstätig genauso wie ihr
Mann doch was den Fußball angeht spielen
im heimischen Wohnzimmer Männer und
Frauen noch immer nicht in der gleichen
Liga gibt das Programm vor
ich würde ihn die Jungs sind in dem
Bereich einfach stärker als die Mädchen
und deshalb gucke ich auch lieber wenn
die Männer spielen zusammen
fast alle in gut doch kennen und
bewundern mbappé einer wie sie der es
geschafft hat einer wie sie aus einem
Stadtteil der von Arbeitslosigkeit und
Armut geprägt ist von Brüchen in den
Biografien
30.000 Menschen leben hier auf einen
Quadratkilometern auf den engen
Wohnungen der Verein bietet Hilfe über
Fußball und Freizeit hinaus unterstützt
Kinder und entlastet die Eltern die sich
oft durch einen fordernden Alltag
kämpfen müssen
wir haben nicht immer Zeit
nach der Schule bis in den Abend können
die Kinder aus gut doch hier ihre
Hausaufgaben machen und spielen der
Verein ist für die Mädchen und Jungen
ein sicherer Ort
man darf nicht glauben dass alles gut
ist wir leben in einem schwierigen
Stadtteil es wird viel gedealt auch auf
dem squarium
ein Papa oder eine Mama zögern eher ihre
Tochter dorthin gehen zu lassen
nachher war acht als er mit seinen
Eltern nach Frankreich zog den Verein
gab es schon damals er ist mit ihm groß
geworden und heute leitet er den
Sportbereich früher erzählt er standen
nur die Jungs im Fokus
die Mädchen waren früher eher zu Hause
in der Küche das ist noch nicht mal
überspitzt gesagt aber so war die
Situation als wir angefangen haben und
das war wirklich viel Arbeit
Überzeugungsarbeit in den Familien wir
haben ihnen erklärt wieso der Sport so
wichtig ist warum die Mädchen
gleichberechtigt zu den Jungs ihren
Platz in unserer Organisation haben
hier lernen Sie mehr Verantwortung zu
übernehmen Lina schaut nach der Schule
vorbei im Innenhof besprechen Sie die
nächste Saison ein Infoabend soll
vorbereitet werden und nachher will den
älteren mehr Aufgaben übertragen
du solltest morgen auch da sein wir
besprechen dann wann wir uns im
September wieder treffen bereiten die
Formulare vor und stellen die Mannschaft
für das nächste Jahr zusammen dann
spielen wir im Wettbewerb wie die Jungs
haben wir dann auch echte Nummern ihr
habt Trikots mit Nummern Schiedsrichter
all das das wird ein echter Wettbewerb
unter der Woche trainieren Sie in einer
Halle es sind die letzten Tage vor den
Ferien die letzten an denen noch alle
zusammen sind Lina freut sich auf ihr
neues Team gefällt sich aber auch in der
Rolle der älteren
[Applaus]
ich motiviere sie ich applaudiere wenn
sie spielen aber auch wenn sie daneben
schießen um Ihnen mehr Kraft zu geben
und wie viele Jugendliche träumt sie von
einer Karriere als Fußballerin Trainer
Samir unterstützt sie verteidige
verteidige halt dagegen bis ich los sage
Lina hofft in einer Mannschaft mit
Gleichaltrigen das ausbauen zu können
was sie in den vergangenen Monaten
gelernt hat
sie haben sich sehr angestrengt haben
sich verbessert das konnten wir in
vielen Spielen schon beobachten während
der Spiele verwandeln dann sind sie
nicht mehr dieselben Mädchen sie sind
viel ernsthafter dabei und voller
Überraschung
doch dann kurz vor dem Saisonende der
Rückschlag wegen der Ausschreitungen in
Frankreich müssen landesweit
Veranstaltungen abgesagt werden auch die
Fett de la gut doch das Sommerfest bei
dem Sie hier auf dem squarium ein großes
Turnierspiel in wollten lina ist
enttäuscht verurteilt die Krawalle
y einige haben den Tod von nail als
Vorwand genutzt um Läden und Supermärkte
zu zerstören und sie zu plündern
es ging ihnen nicht um nael sondern nur
um ihren Vorteil
[Musik]
direkt betroffen von der Zerstörung und
Gewalt waren sie zum Glück nicht sie
haben unter Freundinnen nur kurz darüber
gesprochen wir haben bei Social Media
die Videos angeschaut aber mehr auch
nicht
wir haben im Verein mit den Jugendlichen
die 15 16 Jahre alt sind über die
Unruhen gesprochen damit Sie wissen wir
hören Ihnen zu Sie können mit uns über
alles reden
viele sind entsetzt über den Tod und die
Ungerechtigkeit und dann haben ihr lange
über die Krawalle diskutiert
über den Sport gelingt es nicht nur
Frust abzubauen die Kinder wissen sie
haben einen Platz werden nicht allein
gelassen ein Gefühl das über die
Generationen weitergegeben wurde dank
des Vereins der in seinen 45 Jahren
schon viele Kinder unterstützt hat dass
er glaubt auch dank dieser
Präventionsarbeit sei es in gut doch
eher ruhig geblieben die soziale
Kontrolle ist groß der Zusammenhalt auch
von außen betrachtet sagen alle das ist
ein schwieriges Viertel aber eigentlich
geht es hier familiär zu ich bin hier
aufgewachsen und sehe wie Lina hier groß
wird das macht das Viertel so wertvoll
die Leute sind füreinander da wirklich
wie in einem Dorf
[Musik]
sagt
ich bin hier aufgewachsen ich kann alle
das ist mein das ist unser Viertel
und sie weiß ganz gleich wohin ihr Weg
sie führt die Kinder aus gut doch
begleiten sie
[Musik]